hey wisecrack Jared here today we're
talking about TV's most ambitious
attempt to layer heavy philosophical
dialogue over extended full frontal
nudity West world West world has a
special place in my heart because
putting too much thought into a piece of
art is a hobby shared by both me and the
man in black
I think there's deeper meaning hiding
under all that something that person who
created it to express something true oh
and just in case you don't predict all
the plot twists in the second episode or
managed to realize that the philosophy
of probably means we talk about major
plot points there are spoilers ahead
West world takes place in the eponymous
theme park where for the low cost of
forty thousand dollars a day humans can
live out a real-life open-world game a
la Red Dead Redemption and just like
open-world games
most players ignore the side quests and
only try to rope you in a some [ __ ]
treasure hunt and go straight for the
sex and murder
the most obvious questions raised in
West world are are the hosts truly
conscious do they deserve rights what
separates man and machine and while
these are great questions we're not
answering them today but stick around
till the end and we'll point you to a
video that does instead we'll be looking
at how West world draws on one of
humanity's oldest stories do explore how
free will shapes our understanding of
good and evil welcome Liz wisecrack
edition on the philosophy of Westwood
but first a quick recap there are a few
threads in West's world we'll be talking
about first there's William who ventures
to the park with his brother-in-law and
falls in love with the Android /host
Dolores
then there's the man in black who spends
his time torturing and murdering in
search of a mysterious maze laid by one
of the parks now-dead founders then
there's Maeve the brothels seductress
and chief who discovers she's a host
living in a theme park and finally
there's for the parks creator and
tortured artist who spends his time
fending off encroachments from his
corporate overlords and plotting a robot
revolution thus a West world is a show
about men playing God is an
understatement religious imagery is
everywhere and while all that God talk
is pretty obvious you can't thank Connor
that
Cringer was a devil all the writers also
set up some pretty deliberate parallels
with the biblical story of Genesis it's
through Genesis that Westworld is able
to explore how freewill creates the
possibility for Ethics invoking God's
let there be light stick ford notes
please speak some right words and we
create life itself out of chaos the
hosts live like Adam and Eve in Paradise
they exist in perfect bliss their lives
the way their existence is pure
unashamed of their nakedness if you
didn't month feel cold or ashamed you
wanted to cover his mother see and hear
the voice of God do you remember of
course don't take my word for it the
show straight up tells us in Westworld a
bunch of whispering sets hosts on a
journey towards self-knowledge
which resembles Satan's temptation of
Eve where the Serpent's whispering
convinces her to eat the fruit from the
tree of knowledge thus granting her and
Adam their own self-knowledge and
therefore they have become like God
Dolores in addition to playing the
temperatures to Maeve also represents
Satan's temptation towards
self-knowledge
it's revealed that the flashbacks of
Teddy and Wyatt were altered that it was
really Dolores who massacred the hosts
after Wyatt's program was loaded into
her Dolores as Wyatt is a harbinger of
hosts sentience the head of Armas is a
snake tattoo represents Wyatt she even
says of him he has many names invoking
another guy with many names after Eve's
transgression God punished mankind with
suffering and mortality
likewise Ford maintains the hosts
original state in perfect bliss with the
ability to take away pain and suffering
you need not suffer man take it from
them that all ends with consciousness or
finding the maze and Dolores laments
that it's only caused her pain he told
me to follow the names if anything west
world is like the story of genesis on
Luke
Dolores Barnard Maeve and others gain
self-awareness lose their blissful
ignorance only to be rolled back by for
so Westworld loosely resembles the
biblical story of creation so what well
in doing so the show addresses some of
the same questions about Adam and Eve's
fall from grace that scholars and
theologians have argued for millennia
questions like what do choices mean if
they're coerced or destined can we ever
act ethically if this is the case many
quite logically read the story of
Genesis and think how does an
all-knowing being not realize that Eve
is going to eat the fruit and what kind
of cruel God would punish his creation
for something he's ultimately
responsible for one explanation puts God
in a similar situation to Arnold or for
God wants his children to love him but
knows this love is meaningless unless
they have the power to choose god then
knows that true love only comes from a
being capable of not loving him West's
world offers us three parallels first
bernard wonders why ford allowed him to
explore
his own memories to which Ford muses
even complete self-knowledge and free
will you would have chosen to be my
partner once again Maeve who gains
godlike powers comes to the same
conclusion when she tells Hector I could
simply change you make you funny
that's not and finally if Arnold like
Bernard lost his son
perhaps his quest to bring sendings to
the host is a way of replacing the
authentic love he sense lost love and
obedience
if coerced are meaningless and this
logic becomes even more focal for the
show's take on good and evil this
tension between coercion and choice for
the gods of West world also plays out
between predestination and free will to
prevalent themes in the show
predestination is the idea that God
being all-knowing and all-powerful
has laid the groundwork for all events
past present and future and omniscient
omnipotent being understands because and
effects of all things and as a result he
has a cosmic and eternal naughty and
nice list and has known who will be
burning in Hellfire since the dawn of
time he knows that creating Adam and Eve
will eventually end in their banishment
from Paradise that their offspring will
do lots of shitty things in his name and
that giving man dominion over nature
will culminate in the stuffed crust
pizza Western civilization's greatest
achievement predestination was hotly
debated by theologians because it raises
the same dilemma were faced with in Adam
and Eve can free will exist in a world
where God is all-knowing and
all-powerful what does it mean to live
ethically when these choices were made
in advance by your maker like God Ford
is all-knowing and all-powerful in
Westworld we know everything about
outcasts dumping as we know everything
about our employees and has created the
seemingly human behavior of the host
through a series of predestined loops
that interact with other hosts and
guests and a predictable knowable lay
Hector will steal an empty safe it's the
ending you are given Clementine will
seduce guess how much Ryan and Dolores
will witness her father's death or as
Dolores that Lee notes in the first
episode there's a path for everyone
their crimes or triumphs are no more
less meaningful or good or evil than a
clock striking midnight
it's this lack of choice this
predestination which helps humans
justify their misdeeds in the park they
claim the hosts lack freewill and make
the leap that they therefore also lack
consciousness you never understand the
game is rigged they're here to be the
loser whether or not this is true is up
for debate but for the characters
freewill and consciousness are entangled
if the fact that the hosts have
predetermined loops defines them as
automatons freewill
anchors their claim to consciousness I
think when I discover who I am I'll be
free mave when asserting her own free
will proclaims man [ __ ] story though
this logic is flawed the ability to
choose to do good or evil separates man
from machine West world goes so far as
to suggest that the hosts aren't the
only ones lacking freewill as for notes
we live in noops as tight and as closed
as the hosts too seldom questioning our
choices what would this mean then for
our own human ethics let's also not
forget that just as the hosts are
jonesing for freedom so too are the
guests the newcomers are just looking
for the same thing we are a place to be
free here Westworld suggests a kind of
unfreedom existing outside the park in
our own lives in a world where our lives
are defined by societal pressures to get
a job and a house with a white picket
fence where marriages are often
professional posturing marrying my
sister whom incidentally you seem to
completely [ __ ] forgotten about Ford
suggests that we become no more free
than the hosts people come to Westworld
were reminded to be free to see who they
really are but this too is a lie a lie
that best explains how william came to
be the man in black just as freedom
becomes meaningless in a predestined
world where everyone's path has been set
by a divine creator so too does it
become meaningless in the Park West
world isn't necessarily unethical it's
lacking ethics entirely the show
indicates this in some pretty cool ways
when Hector's gang slaughters droves of
people in Sweetwater
we hear an instrumental rendition of the
decidedly bleak Rolling Stone song
black
[Music]
but the instrumentals robit of its dark
tone and make it flippant and even silly
just as Hector's murders raid is without
meaningful consequence just as Adam and
Eve could only judge right and wrong
after eating the fruit of knowledge
William can only do right or wrong when
Westworld becomes in his words real we
could simply believe that William is
some obsessive-compulsive completionist
out to find the last Easter egg in the
game of Westworld
but it wouldn't be giving the man in
black the credit he deserves I might
even go so far as to suggest that the
man in black isn't evil and is actually
the only guest in West's world searching
for the conditions for ethics the
ability to do right or wrong good and
evil play a strong visual and thematic
role in the show when William first
enters the park he's given the choice
between the white and black hats his
counterpart Logan Don's a black outfit
to represent he's opted for the family
unfriendly version of the parks game
despite this good and evil don't
actually exist in the park if the hosts
are pure unfeeling Utama ton's without
choice
for guests doing the right or wrong
thing is of no consequence in a world
where there are no stakes photographer
as Logan reminds us even it's a [ __ ]
game this also holds true for the hosts
if they sin or love or results of
cannibalism it's only a matter of
programming they're no different from
Ford's childhood greyhounds snapping a
rabbits neck he told me I was a killer
it wasn't it's phones who's made that
way it's his realization that West's
world is a sham that sets William down
his dark path despite all of his
do-gooding when he sees Dolores revert
to her original programming
William is confronted with the fact that
nothing he did matter
despite his white hat approach and
compassion towards Dolores he wasn't
able to do good everything was simply a
game when he murders may even her
daughter he aptly says I wanted to see
if I had
something truly evil aside from
literally wondering if he could play
black hat he's also confronted with the
reminder that he's utterly unable to be
evil when there are no snakes I felt
nothing
just as Dolores reminded him that he was
unable to be good but the spark of
consciousness in Maeve sets him on his
own path the path for truth the path
that will allow actual good and evil to
exist in West world for William the maze
which represents consciousness for the
host is like a glimmer of authenticity
in this fake world unable to find
authenticity in the real world for
whatever reason William searches for it
in West world the younger William
laments the Dolores that he's been a
pretender his whole life I've been
pretending acting to do things only so
that he can fit in forgoing his own
authentic choices contrasted with this
spiel to Lawrence we learned that the
fakeness of Westworld that bothers
William is likely also the fakeness of
the real world this lack of real choice
or consequences or closes the
possibility of doing good or evil
because if you did consider your choices
he was confronted where the truth you
could not comprehend that no choice you
ever made was your own you have always
been a prisoner what if I tones
I'm here to set you free Williams real
goal in all of this is for his actions
to have consequences this is all
foreshadowed in the first episode when
he tells Dolores and then pay all this
money because I wanted easy I want you
to fight not to put on the airs of a
fight but to actually harm him in the
season finale he's visibly disappointed
when Dolores won't shoot him and only in
the final scenes when he's shot by an
army of hosts does he finally seem
content what William has finally
achieved is the condition for ethics
earlier we're told winning doesn't mean
anything that someone else loses which
means you're here to be the loser but we
could say the same thing about being
ethical good doesn't mean anything
unless we're able to be evil which
brings us to the next theme in Westworld
suffering according to Arnold suffering
is critical in the development of
consciousness and the realization that
the world is not what you wanted it to
be that was on those key insight thing
that led the hosts to the wakening
suffering so why is suffering so
important for consciousness in West
world suffering creates the stakes of
Westworld if hosts can experience pain
then guests can be evil and torturing
them or good in saving them suffering
allows hosts to do good or evil to each
other it becomes a precondition for
Ethics in a sense all this choice we've
been going on about is meaningless
without suffering to be aware of pain in
West world is synonymous with
consciousness even William who seems
interested in bringing consciousness to
the host tells Lawrence when the
suffering that's when your most real
returning to the story of Genesis Eve's
free will allowed her to violate God's
will but also eat from the tree of
knowledge the tree that revealed to them
good and evil in this way the fall of
man is like the origins of consciousness
in the theory of bicameralism mentioned
in the show and also shout it out in the
final episode title a bicameral mind
when we stop listening to the voices in
our head and begin judging things for
ourselves we are truly conscious and
with that consciousness brings the
consequences that God wrought down on
Adam and Eve mortality suffering and
expulsion from paradise
the season concludes we learn a few
important things first the maze was
Arnold's test of consciousness for the
host one successfully passed by Dolores
second after Arnold realizes he can't
stop the park from opening and that he
can't stop his sentient creations from
unspeakable torture he loads the code of
a murderous Wyatt character into Dolores
this story and the death of Arnold we
learn are the flashbacks we've been
seeing of Teddy and Wyatt
finally for reminds Dolores that she
killed Arnold hands her a gun and then
goes to unveil his new story this all
leaves us with one final question did
Dolores kill Ford of her own volition
and thus assert her own consciousness
and free will in the style of the show
the finale of season 1 ends with a
repetition Dolores killing Ford is
almost identical to her killing Arnold
but with this repetition also comes
difference Arnold who wanted the host
who loved him by their own choice
programmed Dolores to kill him in his
final resignation board however out to
bring consciousness and freedom to the
host lays the groundwork for his own
murder in a different way Ford's murder
inverts the story of Adam and Eve God
allowed Adam need to disobey his will in
order to make their love meaningful Ford
allowed to lawyers to choose to kill him
to make her violence meaningful or in
his own words and a kidding this time by
choice Westworld then ends with original
sin the point at which the hosts have
lost their blissful innocent state is
when they're able to harm the guests as
much as we can write about the unfree
ethicist conditions of West world the
show also asks us to look at our own
lives if Ford is right and we live in
our own pre-program loops pretending to
enjoy doing whatever others tell us what
does that say about meaning in our own
lives if choices are not really our own
then what actions do we have to take to
break out of this now that we've covered
free will and all this Bible jazz you're
probably dying to know do robots deserve
rights click here to watch our friends
that in a nutshell answer that question
and make sure to subscribe to their
channel while you're there in a nutshell
explores incredibly thought-provoking
questions with some of the most
beautiful animations around so go watch
their robot rights video now and
subscribe
[Music]
you